hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no no
[Música]
que tanto creen haber aprendido hoy
muchos dirían
según levin house hoy en la noche cuando
estén en su casa listos para acostarse
cada uno de ustedes va a haber olvidado
el 60% de lo que escucharon hoy
y dentro de unos pocos días para el
domingo el 80% de la información
se habrá ido para siempre
con este dato aterrador sobre todo a
cierta edad
para que seguir con la conversación
seguimos porque no perdemos la esperanza
a lo largo de la historia los seres
humanos hemos tratado de encontrar
patrones y relaciones los hemos buscado
en la naturaleza en el arte en la
ciencia
volteamos en la noche a un cielo cargado
de estrellas y nos parece ver una
constelación y le damos nombre
vemos un cuerpo humano y encontramos
medidas y proporciones y tenemos al
hombre de vitruvio
buscamos la secuencia perfecta en la
naturaleza y tenemos la de fibonacci nos
encantan los patrones las constantes
encontrar que tienen en común humboldt y
darwin sería una tarea demasiado fácil
pero qué tal si tratáramos de ampliar
esa comparación y buscáramos lo que
tienen en común ellos con personajes
como sor juana picasso hemingway
beethoven
que tenían todos ellos en común
cómo será la constelación que podemos
armar con sus nombres
lancemos hipótesis
pensemos que los une una curiosidad sin
fin y si la mayoría eran unos tipos
curiosos pero no estoy tan segura de que
nietzsche o beethoven hubieran
considerado la curiosidad como su
principal cualidad
si seguimos buscando coincidencias vamos
a encontrar que algunos fueron
contemporáneos muchos europeos casi
todos hombres
pero estas son características
circunstanciales y a ninguno de nosotros
nos gustaría ser recordados solo por
nuestras circunstancias
que será pueden su profesión pero
tenemos escritores científicos filósofos
músicos
que los unía entonces que tenían en
común
todos desconfiaron de la memoria
y que es la memoria que les parecía tan
sospechosa
la memoria es una facultad que
compartimos con varios animales varía
enormemente de una persona a otra y aquí
viene otra mala noticia suele
deteriorarse con el tiempo
la memoria es la capacidad de recordar
es decir una cosa es la memoria otra
cosa son los recuerdos gracias a la
memoria somos capaces de evocar los
recuerdos de traerlos a nuestro presente
a voluntad con más o menos dificultad
vamos a poner un ejemplo
si yo les pido que recuerden cómo
llegaron hoy aquí
a nadie le van a sudar las manos con esa
pregunta fácil son capaces de reproducir
casi de manera inmediata en su mente qué
medio de transporte usaron qué ruta
siguieron si venían manejando ustedes
que venían haciendo y llegaron aquí
pero qué tal si les pido que recuerden
lo que cenaron el jueves en la noche
empiezan los problemas espérate que díaz
hoy y ayer el jueves que hice y a menos
de que sean medio aburridos nes como yo
hice en todos los días lo mismo pero
entonces no sería un ejercicio de
memoria les va a costar trabajo acceder
a ese recuerdo que tiene apenas unos
cuantos días
recordar tiene este significado
romántico de volver a traer al corazón
es lindo es lindo lo que significa la
palabra pero en estas idas y venidas
hacia el corazón se pierde información y
con ella experiencias melodías adjetivos
y es que los recuerdos que descansan
solo en la memoria son frágiles son
efímeros en el mejor de los casos vamos
a ser capaces de traerlos al presente
como una reinterpretación de la
experiencia pero en el peor de los casos
evín house decía en el 80% de los casos
simplemente los vamos a olvidar como su
cena del jueves
sin embargo quién soy yo si mis
recuerdos
quiénes son ustedes y sus recuerdos
gracias a ellos yo soy capaz de mirar
hacia atrás y reconocer al ana paula de
ayer de hace 10 días 6 meses 5 años 10
15 30 años y hasta aquí llegué no porque
no les quiera revelar mi edad sino
porque mis primeros diez años de vida
están en ese 80% del olvido al que he
perdido acceso
sin embargo gracias a esta línea que soy
capaz de trazar puedo llegar hasta aquí
hoy y decirles esta soy yo
porque en los recuerdos pintamos nuestra
identidad
gracias a ellos sabemos quiénes somos
y cómo es que si son tan importantes los
dejamos en manos de una facultad como la
memoria que navega sin remedio hacia el
olvido
a quien de ustedes no le angustia pensar
que un día no van a poder recordar este
momento
que no van a ser capaces de traerlo a su
presente
a mí me angustia y a juzgar por sus
caras a ustedes también
y si no sirve de consuelo a virginia
wolf ya hemingway también les angustia
va por eso desconfiaban de la memoria
por eso necesitaban otra cosa
juntos no recorrió el orinoco esperando
recordarlo todo a su regreso alemania
prueba de ello es que se embarcó con una
libreta en el bolsillo y un lápiz entre
los dedos
sin embargo claro dispuesto a conocer ya
descubrir
pero sobre todo iba decidido a registrar
lo que vivía a aferrarse a su
experiencia no estaba dispuesto a
dejarla escapar
escribió su libro más importante 50 años
después de su primera expedición américa
no en la cena del jueves 50 años el tipo
tenía 76 años cuando lo escribió sin sus
libretas cosmos habría sido un libro de
ficción
simón bolívar amigo suyo decía que
humboldt había despertado al mundo con
su pluma no dijo su curiosidad tampoco
su espíritu explorador ni siquiera su
gran inteligencia fue su pluma lo que
trascendió
y es que escribir a diferencia de la
memoria es una actividad propiamente
humana
escribir no solamente es desconfiar de
la memoria tampoco es sólo un esfuerzo
por permanecer y por no morir escribir
es dar es compartir
es poner de ser pública una perspectiva
para cuestionarla para pensarla y
repensar la homero cuando escribió los
mitos griegos cuando los puso en un
papel dio lugar a la filosofía
escribir es un acto de generosidad
no me gustaría pensar cómo sería el
mundo si el guernica nunca hubiera
salido de la cabeza de picasso si se
hubiera quedado para siempre en su
imaginación
escribir no solo es de desconfiados y de
generosos es quizás sobre todo de
valientes
se necesita valor para atreverse a ser
criticado
para exponerse a ser vulnerable
para abrir un diálogo con generaciones
que no han nacido aún
escribir es estar dispuesto a compartir
con la humanidad entera los pasos las
obras los hallazgos
y es que escribimos no solo para no
olvidar
escribimos también para no ser olvidados
se llama frank no hubiera tenido un
lápiz entre los dedos
habríamos olvidado su nombre y con él su
vida entera
porque quien se queda con lo que vive
con lo que sueña con lo que descubre lo
pierde para todos
escribir es abonar a esta gran escalera
de la humanidad en donde nadie empieza
en el vacío
fútbol venía de un camino que había
empezado muchísimos siglos antes con
aristóteles ya alejandro magno
descubrió y exploró para compartir para
contagiar
contagió a darwin de su afán y su
necesidad por encontrar patrones y
relaciones inspiró el personaje más
notable de dieter contagió a simón
bolívar de su afán por la libertad e
instigó a jefferson para abolir la
esclavitud
con todos ellos muy suertudos compartió
su tiempo y su espacio
con nosotros sus libretas sus esquemas y
con ellos su visión y su mirada
totalizadora de la realidad
gracias a eso estamos hoy aquí siguiendo
sus pasos
cuestionando nuestra propia memoria y
tratando de encontrar y de nombrar
nuevas constelaciones
y al final parecería que lo que todos
ellos tenían en común y los hizo tan
memorables fue justa y paradójicamente
su desconfianza hacia la memoria
sus textos sus trazos son una batalla
ganada contra el olvido
quién de ustedes está dispuesto a ganar
la siguiente batalla gracias
[Aplausos]